[Música]
hola buenas tardes bueno yo quería
preguntaros qué esperan de mí en esta
conferencia
a un ratillo porque no tenemos mucho
pero bueno dirán algo tendrá que contar
porque ya que le han invitado aquí no
será para contar algo interesante
seguramente porque vienen muchas
personas que lo tienen que hacer pero
seguro que cada uno de vosotros se ha
hecho un esquema mental de aquello que
es lo que voy a contar o que lo que
parece que voy a contar
bueno lo primero que veis soy mujer eso
parece estoy vestida como una mujer y
voy a hablar de tal o cual cosa que
bueno que ustedes quieran creer esto lo
vamos a dejar para el final para volver
a preguntárselo
y que esto lo hacemos todo el rato todo
el rato estamos poniendo expectativas
sobre sobre todas las cosas y sobre todo
las personas con las que nos
relacionamos
pero qué ocurre si esto que hacemos que
son expectativas son tan intensas y
luego no podemos cumplirlas lo que
ocurre es que nos sentimos tremendamente
decepcionados pero si vamos en estas
líneas y si además estas expectativas en
lugar de a cosas que hacemos las ponemos
sobre las personas con las que nos
relacionamos pues por poco en el caso de
estas conferencias y vosotros pensar es
que yo lo voy a hacer genial y de
repente ya no cumplo que no va a ser el
caso las expectativas pues claro os
sentiría y lo menos que pensaría vaya
aburrimiento es charla que está dando
estas chicas que ha venido de sevilla
entonces y luego seguimos ahondando
además si yo pudiera intuir las
expectativas que tienen sobre mí sobre
lo que voy a hablar lo que voy a decir
y yo intentará satisfacerla pero es que
no llego yo me sentiría realmente
frustrada imaginaos lo que supone para
cada uno de nosotros porque todos lo
hacemos que constantemente tengamos que
ir superando las expectativas que tienen
sobre nosotros y aquellas que nosotros
ponemos en otras personas
es un trabajo doble es una frustración
doble también
he querido empezar con esta pequeña
introducción porque es algo que ha
formado parte de mi vida a lo largo de
mi vida personal y profesional a mí me
han puesto papeles en los que yo ni
siquiera me he presentado al casting
para hacerlos para representarlos y yo
también he puesto a otras personas sin
saber ni siquiera por qué lo hacía
porque sí y con esta pequeña y como
decía introducción vamos a empezar con
el primer papel que me dieron el de
mujer no hemos empezado con el puesto en
mujer parece que voy a enarbolar la
bandera del feminismo a decir hablar de
esposas relacionadas con el trabajo que
parece que hacen las mujeres o que está
más relacionado con ellas bueno espero
que no hayan pensado eso pero seguro que
alguien lo habrá pensado y el primero
que me dieron mis padres cuando le
dijeron va a ser una niña lo pensaron la
vestimos de rosa lo compraron todo rosa
prácticamente habíamos en pocas cosas
blancas pero todo casi toda la rosa pues
hará danza será respetuosa y también
bonita se vestirá con tacones y falditas
y algunas veces
pantalones evidentemente pero que las
llevara seguro
mi madre me apunto a karate pero claro
yo ya había pasado por danza pero claro
me apunto a karate porque mi hermano
estaba en karate mi hermano mayor estaba
en karate y mi hermano no había pasado
por danza clara está lo remarcó
pero claro mi madre también remarcaba
esta educación diferenciada que tenía
que venía de antaño y que traía de mis
propios abuelos pero no la juzgo porque
es este deporte que al final me ha
apasionado y ha sido parte de mi vida y
estas predisposiciones que tenía mi
madre a los roles que tenía que tener yo
como mujer y mi hermano como como
hombres me ayudaron a saber que el papel
se puede romper en cualquier momento que
te lo dan y además ella también me ayudó
muchas veces a romper lo sigamos con el
kárate había tres niñas en el karate
frente a 20 niños ahí empecé a sentirme
bastante diferente porque claro yo me
sentía masculina esa es la palabra mis
compañeras de clases nos hacían este
deporte
el resto tampoco yo solo tenía mis tres
compañeras y mis dos compañeras que
estaban conmigo era y me sentía
realmente distinta yo ya había
abandonado la danza seguía con el karate
y era como esta niña que hace tanto
deporte era una cosa o sea hacía deporte
que ya era algo y encima a karate
para colmo era una cosa muy distinta y
claro era abandonar este papel en eso
fue en 1993 y posteriores pero es que
hoy hay autores que citan en 2007 que la
masculinidad la identidad masculina de
los niños estaban muy relacionadas del
deporte de base en primaria con la
práctica de fútbol
es increíble todavía en aquellos
momentos pero es que posteriormente
ruiz tendero decía en 2011 que la
práctica deportiva de los niños era
fundamentalmente de fútbol y de las
niñas de gimnasia rítmica esto estoy
hablando de sevilla las estadísticas de
sevilla es tremendo claro y yo me veía
en mi clase pues veía esa diferencia y
además este autor último que mencionado
también decía que la educación física
servía era un buen una buena forma de
eliminar estos estereotipos que hubiera
desde la niñez y esto ya lo volveré a
mencionar más adelante
llega a la adolescencia donde la obra de
teatro tiene tintes están bastante menos
dramáticos ya y claro aumento el deporte
la natación el atletismo no desarrollo a
la velocidad que lo hacen en el resto de
mis compañeros porque hacía muchísimo
deporte prácticamente me pasaba toda la
tarde haciéndolo junto con los estudios
necesarios y claro volvía a sentirme
distinta pero yo pero yo me preguntaba
por qué debía yo marcar unos roles o
hacer unos papeles que ni siquiera
estaban dentro de lo que yo iba a
decidir aún así me seguía haciendo y
seguía sintiéndome distinta pero no
sucumbir y seguir practicando el deporte
en claro está en esta maraña de cambios
físicos y emocionales se le unían los
estereotipos de mujer cuando vas
creciendo pues ten cuidado cuando salgas
a la calle
date a valer cuando te esté en una
relación porque las mujeres todas estas
cosas que pensamos que como rol o como
mujer ya llevamos instaurado en nuestra
personalidad y estudia algo que no esté
relacionado muy con lo técnico porque
eso es como más
gracias están cambiando estas cosas pero
eso cuando yo cuando yo empecé a
estudiar gracias a lo que fuera estudié
turismo no era muy técnico pero aquí el
rol cambio en lugar de la clase de
karate que eran muy pocas niñas en este
caso eran muchas féminas sentadas en los
asientos y muy pocos hombres cosa que no
pasaba en las facultades de ciencias que
tenían muy muy cerquita que era todo al
contrario o sea la mayor parte de niños
los chicos y nosotras que éramos
las compañeras que eran muy pocas
algo así seguir formándome sigue
estudiando me
me coloque otros papeles me especialicé
en organización de eventos y protocolo
y seguir cambiando estos roles que
parece que tenían sobre mí estos papeles
que me imponían o que yo suponía que me
imponían pero seguía pensando en una
rama que no elegí yo creo que por
contraponer todos aquellos roles que hoy
son expectativas que tenían sobre mí la
educación
pensaba estudiar maestra pues yo dije
pues no voy a estudiar turismo pero al
final porque también ha acabado haciendo
otras de mis pasiones la educación
estudie y estudie la facultad que
gracias a dios para ser maestra de
educación física gracias a lo que fuera
el radio estaba compartido las chicas y
los chicos
estábamos en igualdad de condiciones que
esta vez tuve superar mi propia
expectativa porque pensaba que iba a ser
totalmente al contrario igual que cuando
fui pequeña estudie turismo pero pero
quería ser turismo y tú estudié
educación física perdón para ser maestra
y tuve un punto de inflexión porque
pensaba si voy a ser maestra pero qué
tipo de maestra y yo no quiero
reproducir lo que han hecho conmigo en
el resto de niñas y niños entonces me
topé con la metodología montessori la
metodología montessori es desarrollada
por maría montessori una educadora
psicólogo psicopedagogo psicopedagoga
filósofa antropóloga bióloga y médica
casi nada
que también rompió los papeles de su
historial y se organizó una nueva se
estudió a pesar de la imposición de su
padre en aquellos momentos y pese a la
negación de la facultad de medicina que
le impedían entrar para estudiar porque
en aquel entonces vivió hasta finales
del siglo 20 las mujeres no podían
estudiar ella nació en italia y no podía
entrar a la facultad de medicina en la
pedagogía montessori una maravillosa
forma de educar que se contrapone
totalmente a lo que la escuela más
tradicional que tenemos en la actualidad
dejando el desarrollo natural de los
niños y niñas y manipulando a través de
materiales testados y favoreciendo con
límites un aprendizaje que actualmente
la negro la neurociencia está avalando
como perfectamente cierto
la metodología montessori me permitió
conocer otra forma de educar no
reproduciendo esta vez los cánones o las
expectativas que en este caso impusieron
hoy yo estaba viviendo como futura
educadora y me dirán qué tiene que ver
la maria montessori en este papel que
está contando de su propia vida pues
tiene mucho que ver porque maría
montessori demuestra la potencialidad
que tiene cualquier ser humano de
superar cualquier expectativa y crear
una nueva historia dentro de su propia
vida
claro llegamos a este punto todas las
expectativas y van calando en mi ya
había estudiado turismo
la metodología montessori en barcelona-
especializándome y claro ya tienes cerca
de 30 años en aquellos entonces a eso se
le une que no tienes una estabilidad
personal y profesional claro otra cosa
más añadida
que si la casa la familia a los hijos
claro sigue estudiando sigue formando te
aún así seguir
en formándome y en estos momentos en
aquellos momentos que es lo que hoy se
llama binomio montessori un lugar de
encuentro donde por las tardes me
comunico con los niños de una manera
distinta no son clases particulares ni
tienen nada que ver con las clases
particulares al uso pues desarrollamos
la pedagogía montessori siempre
basándonos en los fundamentos que maría
montessori desarrolló y también es un
encuentro cibernético para seguir
formándome para seguir volcando todos
aquellos aprendizajes que que sigo que
sigo leyendo de la pedagogía montessori
y otras cosas que sigo testeando con con
los niños de las clases particulares y
no y no sucumbir a todas estas
expectativas que se supone que debería
haber debería haber asumido o debería
haber hecho entre la normalidad de mis
amigas o compañeras en aquellos momentos
y también creé mi packard personal con
de organización de eventos es decir esta
vez sí en árboles la figura de la mujer
y pensé es que estos autos con
vencimientos que yo propiamente me
imponía y también desde fuera debían ser
debían ser bien
sustraídos para como decía como hizo
maría montessori sacar toda la
potencialidad que pudiera tener en mí
creo que todos los papeles los perdí por
el camino y me reinventé en la historia
a pesar de todos los cuestionamientos
propios que tuve durante mi infancia por
trabajar o hacer un deporte que no que
no era lo común y también por por seguir
formándome y trabajando por de otra
manera distinta que ya también gracias a
lo que sea sigue siendo la tónica
actualmente y así y así crecí creé mi
propia historia innovando en la
en el área monte soriana y en las clases
que están un poco un poco poco
reconocidas las clases fuera del colegio
y creando la marca personal de
organización de eventos en este sentido
creo
[Música]
creo que hay que superar todas las
expectativas que como decía venimos
teniendo para crear la historia que
cualquiera de vosotros en el que en cada
momento quiera o usted a tener sin tener
en cuenta las predisposiciones o los
estereotipos diferenciados en una
sociedad que aún está está limitada por
género masculino y femenino y como no la
posibilidad de dar a los niños
mentalidad de cambio que empieza por uno
mismo para comenzar hacia los demás y
que es esa necesidad de cambio se
instaure en las mentalidades desde la
infancia más primigenia así que ahora
les vuelvo a preguntar que que los que
esperaban de esta conferencia o de esta
charla y espero que esas expectativas
que al principio pudieran haber tenido
al caso las hubiera tenido las haya
mejorado en cualquier caso y si no por
lo menos haber sido la mejor versión de
mi propio personaje en esta obra y
espero que hayan pasado un buen rato con
las charlas